[Música]
el número de asesinatos armados se ha
elevado en América Latina en los últimos
años solo por dar un ejemplo en Ecuador
Se pasó de seis muertes por cada 100.000
habitantes en el 2006 a 26 en el 2022 y
en muchos países ni siquiera hay
certezas de cuánto armamento está en
circulación en las calles porque
proviene de adquisiciones que son
ilegales vamos a analizar este fenómeno
y para ello nos acompaña Karina
solmirano ella es experta en seguridad
internacional y control de armas con más
de dos décadas de experiencia en el
campo actualmente además lidera el
proyecto monitor del att en la
organización internacional control Arms
y es autora del artículo
detrás de un aumento de armas y crimen
violento en América Latina Muchísimas
gracias a usted por estar con nosotros
Karina
Muchísimas gracias buen día
una parte importante de las armas que
circulan en América Latina han sido
desviadas de manera ilícita desde otras
partes del mundo y muchas provienen de
Estados Unidos Cómo es que pasan las
fronteras y qué tanto se puede hacer con
este tráfico ilegal
bueno Es una muy buena muy buena
pregunta para empezar se sabe a partir
de evidencia y de las informaciones en
este caso que da el gobierno mexicano
que muchas de esas armas que llegan a
México y que luego también se derraman
hacia otras partes de la región
provienen de Estados Unidos son compras
que se realizan bajo la figura bajo una
figura que se llama como hombres de paja
en cierta manera que son compras que en
Estados Unidos se hacen de manera lícita
una persona que tiene el permiso para
poder comprar Estas armas pero que luego
esas armas son desviadas hacia
organizaciones criminales en México
desde Estados Unidos el tema de la
frontera que uno supone que con todos
los controles que hay en la frontera
norteamericana esta digamos este tráfico
ilícito sería casi imposible de que
ocurra la realidad es que se han
mejorado las metodologías mediante las
cuales Estas armas y a veces componentes
de armas se pasan a través de puntos
pocovigilados se pasan a través también
de a veces vuelos comerciales a través
de de digamos navegación Entonces
digamos controlar toda esa extensa
frontera se convierte como en un gran
desafío para los gobiernos tanto
norteamericano como para el gobierno
mexicano que es quien más sufre las
consecuencias de este tráfico
ilícito todos los años en el artículo
que que se publicó hace poco hay una
estimación de que alrededor de 200.000
armas más o menos son las que cruzan de
manera ilícita la frontera
norteamericana a hacia México y Estas
armas digamos son armas además de largo
calibre armas militares que son armas
que en México son difíciles de conseguir
Sí porque las políticas que tiene México
para adquirir armas son muy restrictivas
y los civiles en particular no tienen
como muchas
posibilidades de adquirirlas entonces
las bandas criminales los carteles de
droga y otras bandas criminales operando
en en México y en nuestra región en
general se basan en este gran mercado
que es el mercado norteamericano para
adquirir armas que en nuestra región son
casi imposibles de adquirir bueno es que
usted estaba mencionando a México y la
dificultad que hay así como en otros
países de la región no para conseguir
armas de manera legal y que son de alto
calibre no se estima de hecho que en
países justamente como México como
Colombia como Nicaragua hay más armas
ilegales que armas registradas podemos
achacar esto a los conflictos armados de
los países y si es así Bueno entonces
cuál sería la acción Bueno hay una
digamos una multiplicidad de factores
que explican Por qué hay registradas más
armas o se supone que hay más armas
ilegales circulando en algunos países en
Colombia definitivamente la historia no
cuatro o cinco décadas de conflicto
armado dejó una disponibilidad de
enormes armas a lo largo de todos estos
años tanto el gobierno colombiano en su
momento recibió muchísimas armas
adquirió muchas armas para combatir a la
guerrilla y a los paramilitares y por
otro lado los paramilitares y la
guerrilla también adquirieron enormes
cantidades de armas a medida que se va
disuadiendo el conflicto que se va que
se van firmando los acuerdos de paz
Estas armas en muchas ocasiones incluso
también en Centroamérica este fue el
caso Estas armas cuando se producen los
procesos de paz no todo el tiempo Se
entregan Sí ahí hay una especie de una
especie de déficit Respecto a los que se
denomina en la jerga internacional
procesos de desarme esto es muchas veces
se entregaba el arma más vieja Sí cuando
se desmovilizaba El Soldado Y muchas
veces se quedaban con armas más nuevas o
armas más sofisticadas
y sobre
esto además es que algunos gobiernos de
hecho han incentivado el porte de armas
y sobre esto Le quiero preguntar muy
rápidamente Ecuador autorizó
recientemente el porte de armas para
defensa personal porque este enfoque de
armar a la ciudadanía que ha traído ya
tantos dolores de cabeza en otros
lugares del mundo y pues es que algo
similar se incentivó también en Brasil
durante el gobierno de Jair bolsonaro Sí
Sí precisamente en Brasil durante esos
cuatro años aumentó considerablemente la
cantidad de de armas que que se pudieron
comprar que pudieron comprar los civiles
armas incluso de estilo militar que en
general son armas difíciles de adquirir
por nuestras legislaciones la reciente
medida del gobierno ecuatoriano de de
permitir el porte de armas a mí me
parece que va a traer Consecuencias
negativas Porque detrás de estas
políticas a veces existe la ilusión de
que el arma en sí le va a dar seguridad
a la persona frente a un hecho delictivo
y la realidad es que muchas veces hay
evidencia que dice que en una situación
de enfrentamiento armado con una con un
lo más probable es que esa persona sea
la que ponga en riesgo su vida con lo
cual es ilusoria Me parece que son
medidas de corto plazo Me parece que en
realidad lo que lo que deberían hacer
los gobiernos de la región en lugar de
promover el rearme o el o que la
población pueda aportar sus armas es en
realidad diseñar políticas sí que
atiendan la alta criminalidad organizada
que existe en nuestra región y la gran
inseguridad también que exista en
nuestra región bueno Karina ya para la
conclusión yo a eso solamente agregaría
para la reflexión de nuestros
televidentes que la violencia Armada
está
íntimamente relacionada con la violencia
por el tráfico de drogas y esto nos
obliga al menos a repensar la manera en
que se está dando tratamiento a esta
otra crisis de las drogas ilegales
Muchísimas gracias a usted Karina
solmirano experta en seguridad
internacional y en control de armas
Muchas gracias Gracias también a
nuestros televidentes por seguir
conectados con directo a América
quédense ya vienen más titulares
[Música]